men need purpose when you have children
and you want to be a good man children
give you purpose so if a woman is able
to remove that at will even sometimes on
a whim your life can become meaningless
right i'm fortunate to have never
experienced that i hope i never do never
have to go for any legal troubles
anything like that but if i did and i
couldn't see my daughter i wouldn't want
to live and that's the reality that i
think when women play games they don't
take that into account because they're
in that like you said they're emotional
creatures women are emotional creatures
more often than not and they don't have
the rationale to go actually let's take
a step back and look at this that's not
a woman i'm not generalizing there's
some great single mothers that get on
great with their dads but on the whole
you hear more stories about it and i
think that people are just expected to
just look at men and go oh well he'll
get on with it yeah man he's fine he'll
get on with it like he'll be stubborn
he'll he'll keep a stiff upper lip and
he'll crack on but it's not really like
that for me because you know when we
talk about our emotions about kids you
don't talk to women about your emotions
with your kids you talk to other dads
yes and you don't have that conversation
women don't know how we really feel